una nueva crisis migratoria se detona en
el sur de México en el estado de Chiapas
donde avanzan cerca de 3.000 migrantes
con rumbo hacia la Ciudad de México Esta
es la Caravana más masiva en lo corrido
del 2023 y ellos buscan llegar
justamente a la plaza del Zócalo para
exigirle al gobierno de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dos cosas La primera es
que se cierren los centros masivos de
detención del migrante esto En relación
con la tragedia que ocurrió unas semanas
atrás en Ciudad Juárez por el incendio
que murieron más de alrededor de 40
migrantes y la otra es que se facilite
se acelere el proceso para regularizar
el estatus migratorio de ellos y que
puedan cruzar el país y lograr entrar lo
más pronto posible hacia los Estados
Unidos la Caravana de migrantes que está
ahorita caminando por el estado de
Chiapas partió ayer desde Tapachula ayer
domingo y hoy lunes se encuentran la
inmediaciones de Huixtla sin embargo
todavía quedan más de mil kilómetros por
por delante y es muy difícil que una
caravana de este grosor pues se mantenga
cohesionada porque viajan familias con
niños pequeños y todavía tienen que
dormir en polideportivos como de
Escuintla Mapastepec cruzar a Oaxaca y
finalmente llegar a Ciudad de México Lo
que sí es cierto es que hay mucho
entusiasmo porque lograron salir de
Tapachula que se convierte en un tapón
burocrático y donde suelen estar
retenidos en centros de migración de
allí